Ah, that is creepy, oh no don't do that.
Oh don't foll-ah that's horrible
*terrified noises* aAaaAAAaAAAAAAAAaagggGgGGgGGgHhHHhhHH
*terrified noises* Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Five Nights at Freddy's
We're back at it again, it's ya boi
Markimoo and then..we got Foxy back there being a creepy- Do you-
Oh God you do it too
uhhhhhh
I don't like thAAaaaAt at all!
The audio is probably gonna sound a little shit
Uh cuz I'm not in my normal recording room, but just remember I'm a little shit
so...
Uh...even-steven
Now this isn't the fully released version of this game yet
uh the game
*deep breath* has some work to be done you chubby-cheeked little fuck
I'm gonna punch you in your nose with the biggest of fists
And the lovely Scott Caw-thon
Has allowed me to play it a little bit early. I don't know why he thinks I'm special
Whoa... Oh!
I wasn't even at the options!
Did you move?
Who moved?
Whoo moooved?
op-u-tions...
Oooh "Subtitles ON"
Uh, "Back"
if you're ready. I'm ready
hHhhHrRrrrrRLLLll
Alrighttt
Let's do this
M: Okay,
M: Um?
No, n-no no
Um...hang on a second here
Hold on y-your b- tuchus there. I have no idea if those subtitles were even in frame, if they look good--
I'm kind of just prayin' that they look good
Cuz if they don't look good then I don't look good and I always look good
I'm me
Look at these! look at these bazongas. Look at this. Bazonga!
BAM! You see that shit!
Let's take stock of the siti-ation here. The stage is there,
That's when fuck-o 1 2 & 3 are gonna come rushing out at me and tackle me in my gob
We got a prize booth over there, which I don't remember seeing.
"Showtime," "Replay Title"
Whuzzat mean?
Out of Order? Do I..
Kachunk?
*lever clinking*
IT DON'T WORK!
I'm wagglin' the waggle stick and it no WORK!!!
My fingee… my fingee...
Can I go back? Hang on...
Just for testing sake. I'd hate to get through all this-
oh, wait, what wait. WAIT WHA- WOAH, WHAT DID I DO?
HEY!
Mark: Wait. Wait...
EEUGH!
Mark: WOW!
I don't know why I'm here. I meant to go back to the title because I wanted to change some settings. But,
Um...
Okay.
Why- OOOH
OOOOH!
OOH- (giggling)
HAHAHAHAHA
ooooh...
Oh!
Oh.
Oh-
Oh, buh, hang on i was- i was just- Oh hi, um...
Wha-?
*Mark skims the waiver*
Uh. *sigh*
(mumbling)
THANK YOU I'M TRYING TO READ
*reads louder*
aAaAaAAAAaaaAAAaaa
I WASNT DO-
WAIT *unintelligible anger*
WAIT-
NO-
WAIT!-
WHAT'D YOU- WAIT- HOLD ON-
What'd you say?
wdhwyd- what'd you say about night terrors and real life of manifestations of *uh* fictitious characters?
okay-
I meant to go- alright, it's fine I guess- so, I just have to...
*Voice mumbling*
OH! WHAT THE FUCK ARE YOU?!
WHAT ARE YOU!?
What ehya- I dont even know what you are! You're a bunny with purple eyes-
*eh* A-Are you the purple bunny guy? Are you the purple bunny?
Are you the pur- are you Purple-Eye Bunny Shirt-Stabber™
What you gonna do to me?
Just tell me now
I- I dont wanna- I dont wanna wait for it...
Alright, so I don't know what you are...
Um, I don't know what the cassette was that I got. Uh, let's go to the prize counter. Boink!
He-- oh, ooh- oh- Heeeeeeeeeeeeey
*amazed mark noises*
WoOOoOoow
dats cooooool
What happened to bunny?
bu- purple eye bunny
"Sappoint--"
"Disappointment" "Dated and Unoriginal" "Boring Mild Passable"
"Lemon Chica Bar."
Ooh "Meat Bites"
uhhHhHHHh
faz- bar- (Imitates breaking glass and nomming noises)
OoH dat a coin *noise* doink
Do I-
[coin noise]
HEeEeeEEeEeY I DID IT!
[cheering sound]
Hey, there's something up there. Whoa... Oh ball, Oh do I get ball?
[cheerful tune plays] WOAHHHHHHHHHH!!!
YES!!!
aAh- yes! I've never wanted anything more of my life!
*grunts*
Shit, my ball
Ball?
[cheerful tune plays] AHHH YES- YES! IM JUST AS EXCITED AS BEFORE!
YES!
(Grunts)
H e l l o ?
I got something, I don't know what it was,
Ooh, I don't like you
I'm gonna hold onto this! Doink! Eheheh
I still got ball!
*happy inhale*  you- Aww, you're not there.
aAaww- too bad for me!
Um night... woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah       thats-
Thats so much... game!
Th-That- that's too much game!!
Why's there so much game? What are you even thinking?
Grab! *grunting*
Whazzat button do?
Wait, there's a button over here, sorry I hit my,
Hang on, whazzit-- hang on-- 'scuse me-- DOINK what does that do?
H e l l o ?
I'm looking for secrets!
I'm on hunt.
I'm like the Game Theorizer!!
Call me the Game Thunker™ cuz I be thunking about games real hard!
I'm gonna try to hike my pants up
ball
Night one. Let me keep my ball...
Fuck!
*reading* "Five Nights at Freddy's" "Push buttons" "Pull trigger"
Uh, alright, whatever you say, man. Uh, dOiNK!
oH….
Hello? *phone ringing*
Oh! Can I actually-
hang on- wait no- let me, lemme-- ah!
*mockingly* Hello? hELLO, HeLLo?!
Ooh, hello
[Echo-y noise]
*shook* bRRRrrRf
Uh huh...
Oh!
OHhH
wOhoH
Uh oh
Oh!!
Oh shit!
Oh!
OOH!
Ooh! Don't like it!
Ooh!
d-OOH
OOH!!!
oh OOH OOH OOH
OOH OOH OOH
[monkeyplier noises]
Wait
SHUT UP!!!
I-- I GOTTA GO!!!!
I gotta-- wait, hang on, okay, alright, things are bad!
DOINK DOINK DOINK
HEEEEY!!!!
WHY?!?!?
What-wait a minute!
*unintelligible*
*mocking* tHe BiTe o-- the bite
SHUT UP!!
There we go!
Ok, alright, I know about the bite, alright everyone hold on to your hats!
Um...
Cuz i-i-it's- it's going down...
*singing* I'm... yelling timber
Oh shit
Oh fuck
wah--wai-- what do I n-AHHH!! AOAOAHHHH!!!
IS HE THERE?!?
If I lean out is he gonna be there?!
OH SHIT OH FUCK OKAY ALRIGHT THAT--
That's that's news to me!
Turn that- I don't need to see.
OH FUCK! OH SHIT!
Wait- wha-I thought, did he, did he not?
Did he did he not?
Okay. Alright. Wait, hang on hang on
Okay he went in the closet
That's good. Uhhhhh, stay in the closet...
Oh fuck, oh fuck me.
Holy fuck me!
Oh fuck me!!
Okay!
Well, this is uh- new cut
Wait, well, what are you still talking to me, Scott? No. Oh
God
What's happening?
What's happening? What's happening Oh
Who's doing it? STOP! No, I know you're there! I know you're there! Oh shit! Wait, wait a minute
Hi
Hi, okay. You're gone. Okay, go go far. Yeah. Yeah. Hey, okay who's anywhere?
You...
...Should be there... and yet you're not!
Not there, but you should be there. Well, you're not there. So where... would... uh... SHIT!
Shit!
No... where'd you go?
STOP! STOP! Okay...
AAAAHH! OH! WOAH-LY!
Fucking no, holy shit. That's a big no
Are you there? *yells* What the fuck- close it!
Fucking hell
Shit
Stop. Wait. Okay, just a sweet little touch. Not a big touch- sweet touch. Ohhhh-
Freaky, fuck. Oh
Fuck you piece of shit. Okay. Are you there? Are you going? Hello? Hi. Okay, you're gone. Okay, I think do shit
Okay, jjust gotta be che-(stammers) Thank you, I'll-
Thank you
Fucking, kill me I mean don't kill me opposite of kill me oh you're all hi
I'm sorry. I meant to make this camera a lot more smooth than it was. How do I
All right, this is okay, okay. Oh
Fuck me fucking fuck me you guys I can't explain how actually
Honest-to-god terrifying that shit
Okay
Okay. It's 5:00 a.m. 5:00-(freaks out)
Fuckin you, I see you I see you. Oh, fuck. I see you. Oh my god. I see you. Holy show
Oh
Fuck I'm in the box Oh God game one claim your prize. Oh, wait. No, don't you sack of shit?
Are you serious with this bullshit happening with I know what you alright? Let's do it
Oh
That wasn't what I was expecting Oh
Delicious so delicious
Okay, okay
My poor hands and heart. Oh, I don't have a body I forgot. Okay. All right. Wow, that was really
Freaking weird. Um
Okay, I
Uh, oh hi again
Uh-huh. Yeah
Really? Say what you meant to say carry on kind of are you staring at my beautiful face?
I know I'm really pretty. Shall we try it again. Shall we?
Hi-yah we shall I-I.
shall we shall and we shall do and not because I'm brave and
So are you okay? Here we go. This is um, this is happening. All right, we in it to win it this time
Sorry, I'll I'll be a lot less spastic this time I swear on
Me. Yeah, but you know what?
Hello
Yeah, yeah, yeah, no weird
Right, oh
God what the fuck what the fuck what
Boy, shut the fuck up!
(Calypso music plays)
What does the music?
Wow, wait, why? Okay, you're there. I know you are. I don't even need to look at you. I'm not gonna look at you.
I don't wanna look at you. Did you go away? Okay, you went away. Right? OK, right
Ah- *yells* -YOU DID NOT GO! *incoherent* -FUCKING!
ohHHHH, the FUCK!
*heavy breathing* I can't!
I'v- You were gone!
I don't know guess he wasn't gone I guess, you know, that's silly ol' me! Not gone. Oh fuck
O- wOAH, YOU FUCK! *more incoherent nonsense*
But yOu're not- are you there? Okay, you're not there why are you not th- go away.
Okay, you tooch, you tooch. You're not there. So you're not there yet. So that's fine, but you're gonna be there and you're- you, oOH SHIT
OH FUCK! I SEE YOU!
Hi
Hello you out there? Okay, you're not there. Wait, you're not there. Okay, you're not. Okay, okay
Okay, wait, wait, wait. Wait. Wait, wait. Wait. Hello. Hi. Hello. Okay, no need for that. Hi! You're still there. Great. That's good
WAIT A MINUTE!
WAIT A Minute! Hey!
Ho! LEt's go!
Ok, you- you just went to the- I know you- you're at the door
You're probably at the door? I dunno, lemme close the drawer. Get on the door. Everybody...do THE DINOSAUR! Okay
You still there? You're not there
Okay, you're good! Ok, you're good.
Okay
Chica's good. I'M good
We're all good. You still there? Hey! Okay, ho! Not there. Wait. OH FUCK! OH JESUS CHRIST!
Fuck me!
*creaky noises happen* HEY! WOAH! WO-HEYY! WHOAHHHHHHH!!! WO-HEYYYYY!
HEYYYYY!
Holy shit
What the fuck?
Crimey Christmas.
Oh hi! Hi, I shouldn't have closed the door so s- so early.
Okay, you're... Where are you?
Okay, you're there
Jesus. You're not. Oh, I'm gonna die. Oh I'm gonna die for powers sake, but you're not there yet. Oh fuck. Oh but you're you're you're gone
Okay, you're gone. Well, you're there. Okay, you're there now and that's fine. I'm not gonna make it. Oh fuck
I'm not gonna make it. Oh shit
Oh, no. Wait, Boop. Why there's no one? Okay. No one you still there go away
*symphony of fuck x13*
Shit! Dick! My ass!
- okay, here we go. Boink! Dink! Doink! You there? You still there. You there? You're not there! Okay!
Think the two prong approach is the best. Oh shit! You there?
No- yeah! You're there, but you're not there yet, but you're not there yet! I can-
*Freddy Laugh* oKAY I'M GONNA JUST CLOSE THE DOOR! NOOOOO!
OH fffriCK!
G-GO TIME!!!!! GOOOOOO!!!!!!
Oh Shit. x6
Ahhhh fuck!
You there? OH Yeah, you're there! Okay you're there! You're not there, okay.
Ah, go go- Uh oh!
Uhhh... fuck
Don't do it to me.
Don't. You. Fucking. Dare. Do it. To me.
Who is doing it and why? Put that out.
Where are you? I will fuck you up.
I will fuck you up. I will fuck you- I WILL FUCK YOU UP!
I GOT A LIGHT!
DONT DO I-
(Screams)
Oh fucking christ
Okay, right that was great, um great game 11 out of 11 10 out of 10
Yeah, I'll ge- I'll I'll s I'll I'll do more of this definitely. So soon real soon.
I'm gonna do so much more so soon
Just as soon as I clean the poop out of my pants, thank you everybody so much for watching. I hope you enjoyed this. Um,
Yeah, I enjoyed it. Yeah
That that's that scariest game. I played in a long time. Okay. So thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you thought down in the comments below!
I'll have more Five Nights at Freddy's videos linked in the description and I'll be playing more of this
Just as soon as I can find my balls again. So thank you again. And as always I will see you in the next video, byebye!
*Outro song starts playing*